revolving in oval loops of solar speed
couched in calls of clay as in holy
robes dead men render love and war no
heed lulled in the ample womb of the
full-tilt globe no spiritual Caesars are
these dead they want no proud paternal
kingdom come and when at last they
blunder into bed world wrecked they seek
only Oblivion rolled round with goodly
loam and cradled deep these bones shanks
will not wake immaculate to trumpet
toppling down of doom struck day they
lull forever in colossal sleep nor can
God's turn shocked angels cry them up
from their fond final infamous decay
sylvia plath
it's customary to do a recap of the film
first but in this case I'm not sure
that's even possible things happen they
exist in a sequential order
there are causal and corollary
relationships between the events there
is a story there is no plot so here's
what happens as a summary of what can be
summarized boy is born he has a sister
they make it together forever paths
parents die kids are split up they grow
apart boy moves to Tokyo make some
sketchy friends start slinging drugs has
sex with his gay friends mom brings his
sister over to live with him does a lot
of drugs his less sketchy friend gives
him the Tibetan Book of the Dead he
reads it but doesn't understand it he
gets shot in a drug bust and dies and
then the movie starts there's other
threads other stories but they're
incidental to the film because
everything is incidental to the film all
right context we have to talk about New
Wave
you
French new-wave was a socio artistic
movement in the 50s and 60s that
revolved around revolt against the
established conventions of visual
storytelling in both subject matter and
presentation you're probably thinking of
something like this in your head dad
that your commercial I don't know and
that's good enough for now
generally speaking the goal of exploring
the boundaries of the medium took
precedence over questions about the
audience wait we need to talk about
audience all right
this may seem to be a bit of a no dub
moment but in the film experience there
is a film on the screen and the audience
watching it think of the screen as a
person that is telling the film to the
audience the majority of film uses
narrative in order to transmit the film
to the audience in a way that the
audience can follow and interpret while
in a fixed timeframe some of the NuWave
outers took it as an opportunity to
learn how far they could stretch and
pull the medium while still keeping the
audience engaged while others took it to
see how far they could stretch and pull
the audience while still keeping the
film intact others disregarded the
audience and medium altogether and made
it more about the discussion about the
film politics agenda and gender that
exist around the film though not
necessarily within the film itself how
to explain this in a more manageable way
okay a film that stretches the medium
may play with things like in congruous
settings timeline jumps fourth wall
breaking moments or visual illusions
that exploit the production aspect of
the film one that stretches the audience
may not do anything extreme in terms of
editing or construction but may use
demanding metaphors sparse dialogue and
ambiguous figure language pushing the
audience to keep up or interpret what's
going on many such as 2001 do both
whether you love hate or know nothing
about French new-wave
if you're a film fan then you've
benefited from the children of New Wave
from the first camp of out tours the
medium focused ones filmmakers learned
that you could actually stretch the
medium pretty far and still keep the
audience's willing participants and from
that we get the kind of styles used by
Tarantino Aronofsky and Fincher on the
other foot you get the Cohens Jarmusch
and Wes Anderson and they're difficult
to like characters films about nothing
and stories that just happen there that
brings us up to speed so we can actually
talk about Enter the Void Enter the Void
is a 2009 French film written and
directed by Gaspar know about an
American drug dealer living in Tokyo the
main character is Oscar a hollow waste
of space with no goals or ambition who
was shot in the drug raid when his gay
friend betrays him to the police after
finding out that Oscar had sex with his
mother the bulk of its 155 minutes is
spent following Oscars consciousness
from a detached first-person perspective
as it experiences stuff happening like I
said before there is no plot the
characters have no goals nothing has
worked towards a wrist and there's no
narrative climax in terms of how far it
stretches the audience in the medium
it's not the furthest thing out there
but it's still pretty close to the edge
of what even most arthouse film fans can
tolerate this is difficult to explain
because it's a cumulative effect that
builds up while watching the movie at
any given moment it feels like something
is happening but nothing ever goes
anywhere events are disjointed the
timeline is muddled the visuals are
alienating the music is unsettling the
events are boring depressing shocking
and disgusting but nothing sticks
eventually you lose track of where you
are in the movie 45 minutes have passed
and you don't remember what happened in
them this is intentional on the part of
the director and part of the overall
purpose the film has gained some
notoriety for its depiction of drug use
specifically the first-person depiction
of a dose of DMT or dimethyltryptamine
DMT is a powerful psychedelic
hallucinogen similar to LSD or
psilocybin renowned for the complex
visual fields and fractal imagery
generated during
experience according to many who have
taken DMT the visuals here are among the
better interpretations of the experience
DMT is a major active ingredient in
ayahuasca and Anthea genic drink used by
Amazonian tribes to commune with God's
primal spirits in the inner self and to
practice dying
throughout history psychedelics have
been used to search for higher planes of
existence and comprehend one's place
within the universe a use that is not
unfounded as even in the 20th century
medical researchers discovered the
patients with terminal diseases found
themselves better emotionally equipped
to handle their imminent death after
being administered a moderate dose of
psilocybin the active chemical in magic
mushrooms this concept of practicing
dying is also found in the meditative
practices of yoga including within the
Tibetan sect of Buddhism Bardo the doll
aka the Tibetan Book of the Dead is a
collection of funerary texts that
describes the souls journey after death
as a experiences first the overwhelming
fulness of reality which the impure soul
rejects as incomprehensible and a pure
soul accepts thus accepting Nirvana the
impure soul having been incapable of
ascension wanders the earth and
encounters the forms of the Buddha or
others who have lived above the soul in
wholeness where the soul is shown by
example what it must do to progress
after this if the soul lingers without a
body it begins to experience a form of
entropy karmically impelled
hallucinations which drive the soul to
seek a new body and thus rebirth this
process is sometimes described as a
great spiraling dance through eternity
and while it is not without pain and
suffering it is ultimately a celebration
of life and an idealization of harmony
and perfection it is not unique either
the image of spirals fiery wheels and
cosmic dances are recurrent in virtually
all religions worldwide superficially it
appears that this is what is at the core
of enter the void the thread that
ultimately gives structure to the
narrative that Oscars spirit leaves his
body and experiences the failure to
achieve enlightenment tutelage karma and
rebirth this is where our discussion of
enter the void starts to get really
rough because enter the void isn't about
Tibetan spiritual journeys the
durability and duty of the soul or
harmony
gasbar no has denied that it's about
Oscar soul seeking rebirth and insisted
that it's a film about a man who just
heard about the
Metin Book of the Dead before being shot
and is hallucinating one last time
before slipping into oblivion
in many ways it is a continuation of the
theme that no explored in his previous
film 2002's
irreversible which ended with the title
card time destroys everything knows
films have very much wallowed in entropy
focusing on dark violent characters
whose decisions lead only to misery and
destruction leaving them ultimately
alone and vulnerable the film is ugly
the characters damned and self damned
twice over and the hole is tinged with a
ponderous defeatism it is difficult and
exhausting to watch because what should
be the thread that guides us through is
treated with derision by the film itself
the subject matter is bleak and it
builds only to nothingness it is a
painful film in both construction and
content but isn't that the point like I
said the discussion gets rough here
because the film invites us to step
outside of it and ask questions about
the nature of the film as an experience
for example does a film need to be a
narrative and what does it say about us
the audience when we attempt to impose a
narrative where one has been
intentionally denied should the
statement and intent of the outer take
ultimate precedence over the
interpretation of the audience what does
our willingness to accept or deny the
outers intent say about our opinions on
the subject matter on a more grounded
front enter the void challenges us to
figure out for ourselves what makes a
film good or bad and question what a
film even needs to be does it need a
plot or can a film be something you just
sit and experience fantasia
Koyaanisqatsi and 7 million pictures
think so if the film sets out to confuse
offend and alienate does that make it
good if it succeeds negative emotions
are as valid and real as positive ones
and a good cry is often what it takes to
bring the world into a bit of
perspective in the end whether Gaspard
knows says it's about nothingness or
rebirth Enter the Void is about death it
is in a sense a modern atheistic version
of the Book of the Dead a mediation on
the nature of death a look at our
cultural understanding of what it means
to die and viewing the film as a form of
practicing dying the ultimate metaphor
that encapsulates the film is a bad drug
trip the view
has lost control of the experience and
has no choice but to accept the reality
their subconscious has served up for
better or for worse and learn what it's
like to die cutting through the
sensationalist imagery and the long
unfocused running time I believe that
this is the most challenging aspect of
the film and it's redeeming value as a
piece of art mortality is a universal
human experience and yet we so often
treat it as a villain to be outwitted or
a disease to be cured
gasbar know has set out to drag us
kicking and screaming face to face with
our own demise you may not be
comfortable with his fatalist conclusion
that we all must at one point or another
enter the void but that is the
opportunity that art affords us the
chance of better understanding ourselves
by forcing us to confront the myriad
aspects of the human experience and make
decisions to get us thinking and
disagreeing and raising our hand to say
no I don't think life needs to be
hopeless now if only there were another
film that asks these kinds of deep
important questions about mortality and
wasn't like being slowly crushed by
industrial machinery special trace
approach
they say whoever drinks of itself within
forever
oh thank goodness
you